it started when I was young I would feel
a weird sense that I had already
experienced what I was experiencing I
would go somewhere or see something for
the first time and recognize it like I
had been there or seen it before
the first time it happened it scared me
so badly I cried to my mother and asked
her why everything felt so weird she
told me that it was normal that it was a
thing called deja vu and I didn't need
to worry about it
at that age I basically believed
anything my parents said and even though
it still scared me I trusted her of
course
when my mom told me it was deja vu she
didn't actually know what it was or why
it was so called normal no one did
deja vu was a phenomenon of the brain
that science didn't really understand
and beyond that no one else could have
ever been in my head to really
understand or know what I was truly
experiencing as I grew older into my
teenage years it became even more
intense and increasingly difficult to
ignore a trigger be it a visual or an
odor or a thought or an emotion or
everything all at once would seem to
cause the gears of everything to stop
turning and it would feel as though time
stopped and I became stuck in a moment
whenever this happened it almost seemed
as if I could see things around me in
time the same way I could see things
around me in physical space It was as if
to my left was the past and to my right
was the future and the present was
exactly and only where my body was I
tried to just rationalize it away
convincing myself it was just some
strange normal thing but when I
explained it to my friends and family
they didn't really understand they said
that they all had their own unusual
experiences of deja vu but none of them
shared what I described this kind of
scared me but it quickly became one of
those things that was easier to deal
with by not dealing with it so I didn't
then when I was around 19 or 20 I was
sitting at the kitchen table in my
parents house I was eating soup and
watching TV when a deja vu hit me a
sense that I had already watched the
episode of the show I was watching which
I certainly had not paired with the
sense that my brother and father were
about to walk into the house from the
side door then in the next moment they
did
I told my brother and father what
happened as they settled into the
kitchen we agreed it was just a strange
coincidence and laughed it off together
it terrified me though and I couldn't
sleep the next couple nights then it
kept happening I would have the sense
that I already experienced what I was
about to experience and sometimes it
would seem to come true along with
myself my parents and friends became
incapable of ignoring it my parents in
fact were rather disturbed by it and we
decided it was time to talk to a doctor
to the best of my abilities I explained
to my doctor what was happening she
essentially had no clue what was going
on beyond just general theories of deja
vu which were of course inconclusive and
of no help she found my situation to be
exceptionally abnormal deja vu was
common she said but the intensity and
frequency of my experience were
concerning ly unusual by her
understanding she decided it would be
best if I saw a neurologist after a
period of tests evaluations brain scans
and so on the neurologists found nothing
wrong with my brain and also struggled
to diagnose me beyond just an unusual
case of deja vu however he predicted
that I might have some sort of temporal
lobe damage and was experiencing
seizures during the episodes of deja vu
he referred me to an epileptologist a
doctor specializing in epileptic
seizures I explained to the
epileptologists what I explained to
everyone that when it came on I felt
like my relationship with time didn't
exist not so much that time didn't exist
but more like time and I broke up for a
few moments I explained that during
these moments it sometimes seemed like I
knew what someone was about to say a few
seconds before they said it or what
commercial was about to come on TV next
or if someone was going to enter a room
and that sometimes it actually seemed to
happen after more tests and evaluations
he basically confirmed what the
neurologist predicted and surmised that
I was having many seizures which were
inciting vivid hallucinatory deja Vu's
and causing me to see and connect things
that weren't actually real he said that
the seizures were causing a flurry of
neurons to fire all at once throughout
my brain causing my conscious
understanding of things and unconscious
processing of things to get mixed up and
fall out of sync in other words I was
perceiving things that weren't happening
in the way or order that they were
actually happening the sense that
something had already happened
or was going to happen was a result of
my perceptual experience occurring
earlier or later that my conscious
comprehension this made a lot of sense
and was a huge relief however the
epileptologist went on and said that
there was nothing
showing any evidence of damage or
alteration to my brain on the EEG CT or
MRI brain scans but said that this
didn't rule out the diagnosis and that
normal brain scan readings didn't
necessarily mean I had a normal brain
and that the problem was likely just not
physically manifesting itself I wanted
more than anything to believe him but I
got the sense that even though he was an
expert he wasn't really sure and when I
asked how that would explain the fact
that when I would tell someone else that
something was about to happen and they
would confirm my prediction when it did
he didn't really have an answer and just
brushed it off as coincidence or a part
of the whole mental disorientation of
the seizure I hope that he was right but
struggled to fully believe he was and
despite how similar they might seem
hoping and believing are two completely
different things in response to the
diagnosis the epileptologists prescribed
me dilantin an anti epileptic medication
as well as lexapro an anti-anxiety
medication the epileptic medication
didn't stop the episodes from occurring
and the anxiety medication made me
nauseous and numb after about a month of
waiting and hoping the anti epileptic
medication will begin to work it never
did the doctor began to discuss some
alternative methods and the possibility
of some procedures that might help
however the problem was we had to
determine exactly what and where
something was wrong in my brain before
we could procedurally correct it while I
continued tests and evaluations the deja
vu episodes continued they seemed to get
even more intense and weren't merely
brief momentary sensations anymore but
prolonged episodes in which I became
nearly incapacitated then one day when I
was at work everything broke it was as
if something had been building up inside
me and once it became sufficiently heavy
enough it cracked the surface of
everything it felt like I could see
behind the curtains of reality and saw
all the things that went into creating
the show but would never otherwise see
as a part of the audience
I saw the choreography of all the
particles dancing in and out of nothing
I heard the music of all the quarks and
electrons vibrating in the background of
every object I saw the mask of time in
the set design of space I saw the reason
for the chaos and the meaning of the
meaninglessness I saw the spotlight of
existence isolated on one small spot
center stage and the darkness of
oblivion just one small step behind it
then I saw my whole life all at once
like if each frame of a movie were laid
out on a table and you could see the
first and last
with a slight adjustment of the eyes and
just like how a series of movie frames
is only experienced as a movie in time
by playing it through a projector or DVD
player or file player and so on I saw
that I was the projector DVD player and
file player of my life and that the
whole thing was already there
just like how a full movie is always on
the film reel DVD disc or file no matter
what part of it you are watching it was
a strange ineffable flurry of what I can
only describe as rapidly fast-forwarding
and rewinding everything in my life and
just like watching a movie fast
forwarded or rewound at 6x speed it was
blurring and hard to process but I could
catch the main ideas of scenes as my
unconscious mind worked to fill in the
blanks then suddenly I found myself at
the end and at the end I saw the end of
everything not merely the end of my life
but the end of everyone's I saw the
earth moving towards the Sun or the Sun
towards the earth I saw the world
burning as it degraded into some sort of
chaos I saw that all of humanity was
during my lifetime going to die in a
catastrophe of some random cosmic
circumstance then as if the director of
the show realized its mistake the
curtains pulled back to their proper
place and I came back to into the most
overwhelming state of panic
disorientation and paranoia it took me
about a week to even begin to recover
and frankly I never recovered at all I
worked so hard to rationalize the
experience to convince myself it was a
dream or a psychotic episode or
literally anything else after I finally
built up enough stamina I told my
parents and girlfriend and doctor about
it I went through another round of brain
scans and tests and still nothing wrong
was found the doctor essentially
concluded the same original diagnosis
and he and my parents worked it
convinced me that it was just a severe
epileptic episode and was not real in
the way that I felt it to be I was
incapable of fully coming to terms with
this I wasn't sure what happened or what
was real but I struggled to ignore the
possibility of what it was or could have
been it's hard to see or feel something
and be convinced by someone else that
you didn't just because they didn't
how could anyone else know what I
experienced inside my head without
having been there themselves and how
could anyone else actually know whether
or not I was experiencing something real
even if it was an epileptic episode I
wondered if that was actually more real
than my normal sense of real what if
everything that was real day-to-day was
only real according to
conditions of my normal mind but during
these moments of all my brain neurons
firing at once I experienced what was
actually real the conditions of reality
outside of myself without all the
filters and lenses and perceptual
parameters my brain worked to hold up in
every other moment I tried talking this
through with my parents and girlfriend
and then the next time I saw my doctor
he increased my medication referred me
to a psychologist and began to seriously
consider the implementation of an
electronic brain stimulator to counter
abnormal brain activity
I spent some amount of the following
year or so trying to talk with officials
and scientists and cosmologists and
whoever else might be able to look into
the possibility of issues with the Sun
or celestial patterns or any other
potential signs of problems no one took
me seriously I seemed crazy and I knew
it I gave up and receded into isolation
the biggest problem was that in the
moments of the deja Vu's or premonitions
or whatever it was even if it seemed
like I could tell that something was
going to happen I never knew exactly
when or if I was right there were no
dates or certainties in the world of
deja Vu's and premonitions and so I
lived in fear not only about whether my
premonition of the world's end was true
but when it might occur if it was as I
got older I continued to experience
intense deja vu and permanent ory
breaches of everything like that first
one they were all essentially the same
and despite their continuation nothing
physically wrong was ever found in my
brain far worse and more terrifying some
of the senses and visuals I had during
them began to come true and my life
appeared to in fact be relatively synced
up with whatever it was I began to
realize more and more that it was likely
something beyond seizures in this I
started to feel the imminence of the end
of the world as if it was already there
an inescapable cycle between sadness for
what would soon be lost and an anxiety
about when my relationship with my
girlfriend fell apart as I found myself
struggling to love her with the
knowledge that I would lose her with the
rest of the world knowing that
everything was going to end made
everything slippery and transient and
possible to commit to or care about I
stopped caring about my job and my goals
and my aspirations I couldn't find
motivation to do much of anything
knowing that whatever I did whoever I
cared about and whatever I became
interested in
lose the dysphoria between me and the
rest of the world further isolated and
saddened me everyone was going about
everything as normal
chasing things attaching the stuff
committing to stuff trying to solve
stuff taking everything so seriously
but no one knew or cared to know that it
was all about to end forever I exerted
whatever efforts I had towards trying to
master the DejaVu and premonition
experience now that I found myself
recurringly sensing what was going to
happen in the future
I found myself desperate to try to do
something about it I thought that if I
could slow down or control the deja vu
premonition experience I could find a
solution to the impending end of
everything and escape it nothing worked
then many years later it began to happen
a massive rogue planet floated into our
solar system destabilized Earth's orbit
and pushed us towards the Sun I was
right or whatever the premonition was
was right as scientists began to
understand what was happening experts
predicted about two to three months
before a collision with the Sun if we
didn't collide with Venus or mercury
first the earth had about two to three
weeks before everything was so hot the
surface would melt this was initially
faced with worldwide denial and
skepticism then as the size of the Sun
began to increase the world slowly began
to realize the doom of the entire
species in its entire heritage of
species the closing chapter the final
scene with no credits this realization
was followed by mass hysteria and chaos
the leaders of the world broke down mass
suicides pillaging and far far worse
when this happened and my final
premonition came true I was 87 years old
just nine years under the life
expectancy of my generation I
essentially had lived a full life at
least in terms of years in the
approaching final moments as the light
increased in the darkness approached I
sat alone in the chair on my porch and
watched the Sun grow
I drank whiskey as I reflected on how
unfathomably real yet science fiction
the situation was in this moment I
realized that the whole time I knew that
the world was going to end and I had a
choice that came with that awareness I
had the choice to live in spite of my
foresight or live in fear of it and I
chose the wrong one how foolish was I to
know that the world would soon end and I
didn't spend every possible moment and
raptured by it and incomplete the light
over the
that it had not yet I essentially wasted
my whole life worrying about whether or
not I would live a full life which
caused me to live a very shallow one the
true catastrophe wasn't the end of the
world but how I lived before it ended I
was in the most ironic way possible sad
about losing the world and not being
alive while I was alive and the world
was still there like never wearing your
favorite pair of shoes because you're
afraid you're going to get them dirty I
ruined the thing that I feared losing
with the fear of losing it and then just
like I knew I would the whole time I
lost it
[Music]
you